the racial draft is one of my favorites  that must have been fun as hell to shoot  that  yeah because it was one of those things  where you're showing up and it's there's  not that pressure because it's already  written and then you sort of open it up  with like improv and like that little  handshake that we did we came up with  that Colin Powell and Condoleezza Rice  now officially white OJ black again  I get so excited when that killed  uh big thighs no felonies never Gotta  Laugh but I had so many people come up  and quoted this time  I bet they would have picked Oprah oh  well absolutely Rob thick thighs no  felonies she definitely would have been  a great pickup